JJ is with us in Texas hi JJ how are you
I'm good I'm doing good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up so my
wife and I are almost there we bring
about 49 to 50 $100 a month she has a
car that's about $35,000 that we are on
so on it she has about a 6.5 interest
rate on it I have a fleet that I have 20
months left on it and 10 grand to pay
out and we have no house payment and
we've been on the every dollar budget
app for about three months now we figure
out the kinks we've done a lot of budget
cutting and we don't know how to tackle
it gazelle style okay well a good rule
of thumb is to know that things with
motors and wheels go down in value
rapidly right it's very difficult to
build wealth when you have a large
portion of your net worth tied up in
things going down in value so the rule
of thumb that I use even though I love
cars is that things with motors and
wheels that you own cars boats
motorcycles four-wheelers lawnmowers
whatever added together should not equal
more than half your annual income your
cars violate that okay so one of them
needs to go or both of them need do
because your household income is
probably your take-home 660 thousand so
you're also dingos probably 75 and her
car is 35 right yeah so you've been
buying cars you can't afford that's what
stroking year to death yeah that's what
we kind of realized yeah so what is he
owes 35 what's her car worth oh we're
outside down 11 grand on it Generac I'm
trading him personally
she don't like the police about a year
later so we took the car and dragged
another 11,000 all
the negative equity on it okay yeah so
you guys have just been jumping around
all over the place on these car deals
and these car deals are just eating you
alive so yeah you found your weak spot
it's cars and if you can stop that uh
this this boat won't go down cuz it'll
quit leaking so um yeah her car I mean
if your credits good enough I'd borrow
the eleven thousand get a hoopty put her
let her drive your leased car cuz it's
probably the nicer car cuz that's
federal law mom gets the good car that's
federal law and so you know make sure
she gets a good car and you drive the
hooptie and let's get her sold and get
take out eleven thousand not alone
cuz I'd rather you have an eleven
thousand our loan that I would a thirty
five thousand dollar loan and quit
buying cars you can't afford now when
your lease is up you just turn it in and
get another hoop D and then you save up
and pay cash for your move up in cars as
you go along hope that helps you